in 2015 the New Horizons probe stuns
mission scientists when it reveals Pluto
as a dynamic living world its glaciers
mountain ranges and likely volcanoes are
all evidence of an active geology driven
by heat and because Pluto receives so
little sunlight its surface is
bone-chilling the cold as low as minus
400 degrees Fahrenheit
if the heat that drives Pluto's dynamic
geology isn't coming from sunlight it
must be coming from the low but from
where
the best guess is that Pluto has a deep
subterranean ocean of liquid water
and somehow this ocean is driving heat
up to the surface
could freezing water really make a
planet hotter it sounds crazy but Jamie
radabaugh can demonstrate this weird
quirk of physics using an ice bath to
represent Pluto's frozen upper crust and
a cup of hot water to represent Pluto's
hidden liquid ocean at first the ice
bath causes the temperature of water to
drop but as soon as the water freezes
but temperature inside the glass does
something amazing it rises okay it's at
30 so it's definitely ready to freeze so
I just want to give it a little bit of a
helping hand and see if we can start it
to freeze here we go just a little stir
oh oh there it goes now it's completely
frozen and the temperatures is
dramatically climbing like just seconds
after it froze it has climbed climbed
eight degrees look at this it was 30 and
all of a sudden it's 38 just seconds
after it froze it might seem kind of
counterintuitive but freezing water
actually gives off energy to its
surroundings all of that kinetic energy
the motion of the water molecules in the
liquid state has to be given up for
those water molecules to enter a solid
crystalline structure that released
energy it's called the latent heat of
fusion
it actually can warm the surroundings as
water is freezing into ice
[Music]
this is how scientists believe latent
heat in an underground ocean could be
driving volcanism on Pluto the uppermost
layers of the internal ocean freeze
where liquid water meets the hard frozen
ice above this act of freezing releases
latent heat which then travels up
through Pluto's crust driving active
geology on the surface
you